thank you
[Music]
Chuck hey it's time for things you
thought you knew yes and uh and in my
case things I know I didn't know
that's a very important state of mind to
know what you don't know
because if you didn't know what you
didn't know that's just that's just
abject ignorance I mean that there's no
true yeah that's what's that second part
is sad which is sad exactly oh that's
the sad ignorance that's sad ignorance
man
all right so Chuck how do you know how
big big something is
yeah measure you measure it right so you
pull out a ruler let's say if let's say
it's a table and you measure it okay so
there are two things working against you
on that one of them is you know how
close together are the the hash lines on
the ruler right right because if your
table ends up between two of them
then you don't know how long your table
is you if you're going to report to me
you can only say it's between here and
there and Venture guess to where it is
from one marker to the next okay so it's
kind of like half maybe what you'll
you'll give me a guess fine but you
won't know exactly because you don't
have the metrics to determine that right
it's not like measuring in in hands
he's seven hands tall really that's all
my hands is actually a specific
measurement I mean I think the hand is
four inches oh really the width of your
hand uh yeah look at that scene I just
learned something there horse Heights
are measured in hand and hands right I
knew that the horses were measured in
hands but I didn't know that that hand
had an actual unit it's around four
inches don't quote me on that but all
right that's good okay okay
so even if you had the Precision
to measure the length of the table
if you go down under a microscope
like a really good microscope like an
electron microscope that's the kind of
microscopes where you see all of the
hairs on the on the on the bugs and you
know you see the eyeballs of the fly
those kind of microscopes if you do that
you'll see that the edge of the table is
not smooth
it's actually got texture
so which feature of the texture are you
going to measure it to and then report
back to me the width of the table
what happens is at some point just give
up and say Neil I can't you're ignoring
is there anything you can't you can't
measure anything unless you just agree
you just agree
how you're going to take the measurement
and then you're good with that well
if you have that problem with solid
objects Imagine The Challenge measuring
the extent of gaseous objects
just imagine that okay yes I believe you
measure that and how bad it smells
[Laughter]
well gas came out of your rear end okay
in this world just saying
so you can ask how high up does the
atmosphere go
well so you ascend and is there a sign
that says you are now leaving Earth's
atmosphere no
no
the atmosphere gets continually thinner
right and you know this because as you
ascend the mountain
the air pressure drops
it's harder for you to breathe you can
still breathe just every Long's worth of
air has less oxygen in it okay that's
your evidence that the air pressure is
getting lower and lower and lower should
have never smoked Man Okay God this is
killing me
this continues you go into an airplane
airplanes are pressurized right which
means they put air in there otherwise
you would suffocate if they open if you
roll down the windows all right so those
oxygen masks
those are there in case the airplane
loses pressure
and you're breathing very low density
air has hardly any oxygen in it so you
gotta we breathe through the mask that's
all okay by the way you could hold your
breath until you did this I mean this is
not you're not going to die immediately
you have to fight for them just it's
just air okay right you've held breath
holding contests for longer than the
time it'll take you to reach for one of
these yellow masks and remember people
always put your own mask on first before
you try to put the mask on that of a
child
so
which by the way no one had to tell me
okay
like when I when I heard that I was just
like and and what else would I have done
okay
Chuck was first out of the box on that
one I was like I was like this kid ain't
bringing nothing to the table
really
I might I might just let the kid pass
out just so I can get some rest
oh that was the noise Hey kid I'm not
giving them the oxygen
stop being so quick there man
that kid is looking real peaceful right
now
all right that's cold all right oh by
the way it is also literally cold as you
leave Earth's surface because you're
farther away from the Heat point of the
heat generating point which is well
that's another
scratch that whole another explainer oh
nothing okay so as you were saying the
air just simply gets thinner and thinner
and thinner there is no spot where you
say it ends here and and space is no
there isn't
so you just have to agree on what that
altitude will be
pick a thing and then just you be good
with that I'm good with that fine put it
in the books move on to the next problem
okay okay so there's a guy in the 1960s
named Carmen
okay he's Hungarian I think but worked
in the United States and he said there
must be an altitude
above which the atmosphere is no longer
scattering sunlight
above your head
so that it's no longer sky blue
the blue goes away and then you just see
stars
in broad daylight
oh wow that's an interesting threshold
right that is and that's fair there'll
still be air molecules there just not
enough to scatter to because that's how
you get a blue sky it scatters the blue
of sunlight and now the sky is glowing
and you can't see the night sky
you can't see stars in the daytime sky
so because it's daytime however if you
ascend high enough in the atmosphere
there's a point where there aren't many
molecules above you bada bing the sun is
still there but you can see stars in
addition to our own star
in the sky so that's called the Carmen
line
and ever since the early 60s the Carmen
line has been the functional definition
of a transition into space whether or
not you were in Earth orbit
interesting our first astronaut Alan
Shepard went up in 1961 he went into low
he went to um suborbital
was fished out of the Atlantic okay and
he went high enough to go above the
Carmen line so that counted and so
that's sort of our astronaut threshold
Carmen himself however knew that the
atmosphere is not some rigid thing it's
gas right and sometimes it heats up
sometimes it cools down so it will
expand it will shrink and so so those
the carbon line is not itself a definite
thing but if you're going to look for it
it would you find it between
anywhere between 80 85 and 100
kilometers okay that would convert to 53
to 62 miles up
that's like arguing you know which which
edge of the table are you using to give
me the length of the table
except worse because it's gas right
so uh point is the atmosphere continues
out for thousands of miles
oh no yeah in fact wow the International
Space Station which is
250 miles up
right two how much higher than the 62
mile carbon line is it's four times
higher than the carbon line the
International Space Station is huge it's
like the size of a football field moving
through the air there's enough
atmospheric molecules up there to hit
the solar panels and the physical body
to to to drop it to lower orbits than
you would than you had originally
intended
so every now and then the space station
has to boost itself up back to the to
its original Target orbit because of the
air molecules that hit it
that's insane yes
and that's 250 miles up
so there is no Edge
and if you're going to ask me what is
the diameter of the sun you could look
this up in a book you you could look
this up the diameter of the sun it'll
give it to you and you say well wait a
minute the sun is made of gas
so how precisely are you measuring that
you take a ruler and do that not only
that you could say in what wavelength of
light did you measure the diameter of
the Sun do you know different
wavelengths of light
emanate from different locations within
the depth of the Sun
if you if you're like Jordy on on Star
Trek next Generations and you look at
the sun in ultraviolet light
it has a different dimension
from what it has if you look at it in
visible light and if you look at it in
infrared light
then if you look at it in x-rays all
different dimensions in fact the solar
Corona the thing that's glowing outside
of the the moon when you see the total
solar eclipse that's called the corona
which is Latin for Crown so sensibly
right so so if you look at that with
x-rays that's the size of the sun
forget them down on the sun's surface
gaseous surface x-rays the corona is a
blaze with light and you're going to say
the sun is huge
so I just want to say
just want to put it out there that
the the dimensions of things is really
just something you just have to agree to
in advance and then you all agree you
put it in the book and then you move on
so the diameter of the Sun is the
diameter it shows to us using yellow
light which is right in the middle of
the visible spectrum
that's the number you're going to read
in the book
but it'll tell you that but I'm telling
you that I'm glad you did because uh
it's good to know they've been lying to
me
oh by the way and you can think of other
definitions of space I got one for you
you ready so airplanes use fuel
it's called with aviation fuel there's a
word for it I forgot but anyway it uses
fuel so fuel our common understanding of
fuel is you burn it and then energy you
get energy
but what does it mean to burn it
it means it gets attached to the oxygen
molecule uh-huh
creates a third other product right
there's that molecule the oxygen
molecule they merge and make and make
this other molecule and it's exothermic
energy gets generated okay
that's how cars work that's how
airplanes work
but we're just getting its oxygen from
the atmosphere
okay wait a minute but if you're a
rocket
and you're going to where there is no
oxygen where there's not much oxygen you
got to bring your own oxidizer
you can't depend on the atmosphere so
you so you could say I you enter space
at an altitude where an airplane can't
get enough oxygen to fly anymore
and it just drops out of the sky that's
an interesting threshold
you could have done it that way
because above that you need a rocket and
we all know Rockets equal space
okay there you go I can think of 10
other ways you might Define it
but so I'm just I'm just saying just
numbers and measurements of things are
not they're not written in tablets
there you have to agree on what it is
you're trying to measure write down that
number and then move on
there you go measurements not written in
tablets only Commandments
[Laughter]
all right that's all we got time for all
right yeah that's a crazy subject but I
have to put it out there no that's very
cool and when you hear people arguing
over the Carmen line just sit back and
chuckle and say Carmen line is an idea
more than is an actual place within
Earth's atmosphere well if I ever get
into a argument about the Carmen line my
answer will be so how big is the Sun
hey
and also the 100 kilometer carbon line
did you really think the atmosphere is
layered into even evenly divisible
numbers in kilometers did you really
think that's the case
100 kilometers yeah
yeah tight with the with the with the
metric people right it's like no 100 is
well above whatever Carmen was talking
about but if you want to round it up you
round it up to 100 kilometers and that's
the definition fine okay and the
American definition is lower than that
we're like at 85 kilometers up we have a
lower definition than Europe and the
rest of the world do oh well yeah that's
that's because you know we want to be
able to say we went to space we want to
be able to say that Alan Shepard with
the space correct exactly we're the
first people to do it you know right
right right it's just like uh we uh we
put a spire on top of uh the Freedom
Tower and it's like now the tallest
building in the country
exactly all right Chuck we got to end it
there but if you hang on when we return
we'll go into another segment of doing
some explaining
uh you know stuff you thought you knew
that's what this is all about when we
return
so Chuck we're back okay for another
explainer all right uh this one did we
talk about this before I have a bad
memory for what I've been talking about
but I'm gonna do it anyway and if it's
not we'll just do it again here it is
you ready okay okay so there's an
interesting difference between being an
astrophysicist and being a photographer
okay okay here's the difference a
college education
I mean
I'm sad
okay here's the difference
we know
that when you have an object
and you heat it
and its temperature rises it it actually
radiates energy
okay
radio if it's very cold it'll radiate
radio waves and microwaves in fact the
whole universe is three degrees absolute
zero three degrees above absolute zero
very cold at that temperature
microwaves get emitted so the universe
is a source of microwaves upon us
because of that leftover temperature
from The Big Bang
Heat
anything more I don't care what it is
heat it some more
and then the energy it'll start giving
us will start shifting in the Spectrum
and it'll start giving us infrared
energy
okay you can't see it it's not glowing
visibly yet but if we have sensors that
are not our eyes to detect infrared you
know what it's called
uh no touch okay
okay heat right yes yeah if it's if it's
warm you can you can detect low level
infrared all the way up to high level
infrared just by getting near it and you
can feel the energy or you can touch it
and you can and you can feel the
temperature okay okay so Chuck it gets a
little warmer than infrared now it
begins to glow red
and so now it's giving you energy it's
giving you photons in the visible part
of the spectrum say hey that that's hot
that's glowing red hot right okay but I
know that you can keep making the
temperature higher
it'll still glow but now it's going to
Glow white hot and then glow blue hot
and the blue hot is the hottest of the
glowing temperatures but we don't
experience that in everyday life so
we're success blue hot anything anything
they don't say that anything plus ice
and icebergs have this blue tone to them
so psychologically it all feels
different but
here's what's interesting okay
when we transitioned
from incandescent bulbs the old
old-fashioned Edison Light Bulb to LEDs
okay ask yourself why would a light bulb
giving you visible light ever get hot
because it's glowing white hot
but it's also still giving off infrared
okay so but wait a minute I have a light
bulb so that I can see
so the 100 watt light bulb or whatever
the wattage you bought
it turns out most of that energy is
coming out in the infrared yeah yes it's
a waste
which is why they would always say on
the package it would say
um
wait until wait for whatever you know
however long before changing the light
bulb because so many people be like like
the light bulb would blow out they would
go get another light bulb come back
well go to change it and burn their
hands that's how hot the bulb was it's a
complete waste of everybody's energy the
fact that we have light bulbs that was
giving us infrared wow so the brilliant
thing about LEDs
and let me remind you LEDs are of this
next Generation interior lighting we
couldn't do it until we had all three
colors of LEDs we had red LEDs right we
had green LEDs we didn't have blue
and that would once we got blue we'd
have RGB you can combine them
and RGB combined in light don't this not
doesn't work this way in paint don't
tell your artist friends this you
combine RGB with light and you get white
light the thing about LEDs is they're
not glowing
did not glowing from heat it's actual
white light it's actual light coming out
at those frequencies at the red
frequency at the green frequency at the
blue frequency your eye merges them and
you see it as white light there is no
energy coming out in the infrared or
anywhere else
so that's why you could have a three
Watt
yes LED bulb that just kicks ass against
a 60 watt or whatever many five Watts
whatever and it's a 60 watt Edison bulb
regular old-fashioned bulb because most
of that Anderson energy is coming out in
infrared and none of that energy is
coming out of infrared for the LED it's
all in the visible part of the spectrum
I
does two things and it's so exciting
that you just actually did everything
you just did and related it to light
bulbs one
people went crazy when uh we said we
were going to transition to all LED
light bulbs and they did it because uh
president Blacula said that we should
actually that we should actually move to
all LED light bulbs and people were like
ah now the government's trying to tell
you what kind of light bulb you have no
I swear to God it's my God getting right
to have me a regular incandescent light
bulb that's America and so people lost
their minds this judgmentation of
America
they lost their minds they lost their
minds and what you were saying is one
um it's more uh it's it's more efficient
because it is exactly what it is which
is so it's energy efficient it's like a
factor of ten okay and then the other
thing you said was that is why
you see on the box it's whatever many
wants instead of like your 200 watt bulb
whatever it's like you know it says if
they do lumens now yeah you can't use
watch because you know what watts are
watch is not the measure of the
brightness of anything right which is
the measure of how much energy the rate
which is consuming energy and since we
all have the same light bulbs you could
compare watts and say that one is you
know twice whatever you had you had some
sense of that right but really with
light bulbs it should have always been
measured in lumens in fact in Europe I
think they always measured it in lumens
so you really you're after lumens here
you're not after wattage okay
so this is a maturity of the American
population yeah it's this is this is the
best reason for you people to go out and
get LED lights I mean for me you know I
got into this because it's great for the
environment you know if we all did it we
would really lessen our carbon footprint
for the entire nation but the fact is
here's why you should do it you save
money you just you just proved how much
more efficient it is you save your own
damn money even if you don't care about
the environment care about your own damn
wallet there you go so and that's why
you can go up to any LED bulb and it's
not hot it'll never be hot
it's not about being high yeah exactly
and
what and I don't like science and other
the person who
got a Nobel Prize for that because the
moment that got discovered it blew open
the entire lighting industry
because now you can make white light in
fact you can make any color light that's
why you can get LED controllers where
the the light itself has an RGB diodes
in them
um and you can just control the ratios
of those and get any color you want
and so you can the Empire State Building
is lit by these things okay and it's
very into the intensity of the color is
very real and it's very in the in the
moment so
so just thought I'd tell you that that's
super cool well listen white light was
what we were striving for but always
remember only black light can make your
dorm room look cool
hey
oh by the way so black light just to be
clear is an ultraviolet light but the
part of it you see is the Violet that's
just kicking into the red orange yellow
green blue violet part of the spectrum
you can see that but that's not why you
have it in your dorm room you have it
because the ultraviolet light interacts
with the pigment in the pictures on your
wall the posters and it forces the
pigment to Glow
okay and it it's it's called
phosphorescence right and so that high
energy light that you can't see the
pigment can see it absorbs it and then
gives it back to you invisible light and
it looks like the paintings are glowing
so in a sense it is black light it is
light that you can't see nice yeah all
right
well this was great you got it Chuck
so next time you walk by a a an LED just
pause and say thank you science there
you go
say that anyway
just say that anyway
wake up in the morning take a deep
breath thank you science
I should tweet that I'm going to do that
let me see if I can start a movement so
Chuck that's the end of this segment
when we come back we're going to do
another one of these chuck all right so
you got it in you to listen to it okay
all right we'll be right back
Jack hey Neil I'm back with another sort
of stuff you thought you knew
this one might be something you didn't
even know you didn't know okay there's
some of those are out there too right so
no one told me this I discovered this on
my own that if if for those of you who
have ridden airplanes I know some people
have never been in an airplane I highly
recommend it it's quite a Marvel of
engineering and physics and yeah and and
aerodynamics or you could watch YouTube
okay okay
so if you could save up if you've never
been on an airplane find a place to fly
to and just check it out it's it's quite
a Marvel and I I Marvel it every day
even though we've been doing it for more
than 100 years so I noticed when I pull
down the shades and I can't see outside
and I look at this drink
and the water level is completely
horizontal okay
that means we're just there we're not
you know accelerating or banking or
turning right okay it's just there
and
it stays that way the entire trip
right
now I know the plane has got to make
some turns when it comes near I know
it's got to do this at some point right
yes
if it does that I would expect the water
level to tilt within the glass
I'd expect me to lean
in one way or another at the way it
would happen in a car if you make a a
left turn in a car your body
leans to the right
okay because you actually want to keep
going in a straight line but the car is
curving in front of you so it feels like
you're getting pushed to the right but
really you're just going in this you
want to go in a straight line the car
won't let you you're getting pushed
against the door okay or you turn left
or right whichever or someone sitting
next to you your shoulders will touch
all right no longer does that happen on
an airplane
so what I did was let me try this with
the shade up I do it with the shade up
I look out this window I see Sky I look
out across the plane I see the ground
this sucker is banking and yet the water
on my table is completely flat okay
so
there's only one thing that can be
happening here because I don't think
humans have this ability
the computer is flying the airplane
and you program into the computer
such that the radius of the turn
and the speed at which you're going
requires that the plane be at a certain
banking angle
so that all the centrifugal forces
combine with gravity
so that
you don't even know you're banking this
term
in other words the urge to fall into the
middle of the circle gets completely
balanced with the centrifugal force to
send you out of the circle so that the
gravity Vector still goes directly to
the bottom of the glass and to your rump
into the chair and you don't even know
the plane is turning
those three numbers if you if
correctly you can have them conspire so
that you would never know the plane was
ever turning at any time well clearly
you have never been on Spirit Airlines
the Pilot's in there
they don't even they don't even use the
joists they use a actual steering wheel
[Laughter]
I'm sure it's a fine Airline where they
have fully trained pilots
but the Precision necessary to do that
to do that reliably to do that without
the Judgment of the pilot is
um
uh that that takes a computer and if you
look at old movies where they show
people on airplanes and this airplane is
turning you'll see people sort of
leaning to the one side or the other
that is no longer a thing in airplanes
and
reminded me of
going back is old episodes of Star Trek
the first Star Trek where the entire
crew would go to the left and then
they'd go to the lead hold on
and it'll all be instructed to do this
right so do they take the camera and tip
the camera and they tip the camera and
they would all do that to make it look
like they were bank and they were in
space so
so if you if you Bank a turn properly
you never feel that that effect and by
the way we've talked about this with
NASCAR all right what the banked turn
in a race track
there is a speed with which you can
drive your car
so that you never have to touch the
steering wheel and the car will make a
complete turn on that bank and end up
going back the other way
right and that speed is one where you
will not feel like you're leaning to the
left to the right
because the road is turning for you the
road is turning the car for you correct
and at the right speed you'll feel the
gravity Vector doing whatever we're
doing before you enter that turn it's
the same physics principle
at work there
so I just thought I'd put that out there
just a little Discovery I made I haven't
checked with anybody who did it and when
it started but I began noticing it and
you should notice it too
check it out yeah
the guy here and brown down there and
you don't even notice it unless you look
out the damn window yeah yeah the same
well yeah iFly Spirits so I've noticed
it all the time
top wait one last thing
if you are
in space uh-huh
there is no banking of terms
yes okay well I'll tell you why because
because so so on a track the thing
that's turning the car for you is the
road itself okay okay that's a force
there that's turning the car
if you are in an airplane you are
banking on a cushion of air
as you complete your term
if you're in space there is no Force
doing that
so if you're in space you just have to
fire Rockets
right and and so so they don't tip and
turn uh it looks cool when the Tie
fighters did that in Star Wars and and
the Millennium Falcon you know it looks
cool but that's not how it would happen
you just have the Rockets change the
direction
um that that it turns in so all of those
Maneuvers that you see the Millennium
Falcon make when in yeah they're
Maneuvers for their atmospheric
Maneuvers they're not yeah none of that
means anything right right it's right
yeah wow plus didn't they at the end of
the Star Wars episode four when they had
the the you know the uh they were
celebrated for destroying the the the
Death Star the Death Star they didn't
they just fly in from an open Bay
exposed to the vacuum of space
and then they just get out and walk
around
yes
I see uh but I think there's a Force
Shield that holds the atmosphere inside
the ship though well you just made that
up right now no no I'm serious
okay okay
I think that's how it works okay magic
force fields okay like yeah
I mean but seriously there is nothing in
Star Wars that that's scientific let's
be honest I mean seriously there's you
know the least believable thing to me
was here's the here are the fighters
coming in and there's the guy
right
you don't have a better way to do this
in the 25th Century or whenever the hell
this thing takes place and the other
thing is too they all fly in and um
nobody fires retro Rockets
oh they just slow down they just slow
down like in Star Trek though when you
fly into a shuttle Bay uh there is a
kind of like a tractor beam that grabs
you and then you come in and that's
correct correct because Star Trek thinks
about science yeah but Star Wars they're
just like you know coming in they're
coming in hot
all right so this is this is airplane
banking 101 check well that's cool
actually all right this has been
Embry
stuff you thought you knew in three
segments and so I hope you like these
Chuck because I you know I bend your ear
on them I love them they're great I mean
and I actually do learn
s and I gotta tell you man that I mean
they're they're it's really it's great
information to have at a cocktail party
okay because you'd otherwise just be
completely boring I gotta pull out a
nihilism here just exactly it's like you
just go talk to that guy I thought it
was a comedian but God is brilliant guys
brilliant
yeah
I thought he was a stupid comedian
so Chuck we got to call the quits there
but uh this has been fun I'm glad to to
teach a couple of things yeah I mean I'm
an educator and I feel like I have
purpose in life and that I'm somehow
fulfilling that purpose if I get you to
learn something because you're a smart
guy and you know a lot so it's a
challenge for me to find things that you
might not know really I'm just telling
let you know that well there you go
that's uh I don't think it's much of a
challenge
Alex I'll accept that as a compliment so
another stuff you thought you knew uh on
Star Talk
Neil deGrasse Tyson as always
[Music]